drücke ich mich vor diesem video okay
leute shit is going down chips grings
somit schauen dass ich ein ritter video
machen muss ich drücke mich schon die
ganze zeit vor weil das dann die sache
so echt macht dass sie jetzt pause
brauche wie es vielleicht im titel steht
ich weiß nicht was für ein klick bett
titel ich mir überlegt habe damit ihr
auf dieses video klickt aber ich wollte
ankündigen brauchen wir sie pause und
gleichzeitig das fenster zu machen aber
warum vanessa warum brauchst du pause du
hast auf den einfachen job der welt und
hey du machst du einfach nur aus spaß
macht ja komisch es ist einfach so
komisch ich verstehe es nicht
ich vermute manchmal dass es dieser
soziale druck ist dass man so viele
meinungen hört zum beispiel habe ich in
den letzten videokommentar bekommen dass
meine haare hässlich sind und erstmal
muss über dieses kommentar lachen aber
danach war es so richtig in mir drin und
ich hab das nicht mehr los gekriegt ab
dem moment habe ich mich im spiegel
angucken hab gedacht verdammt ich hab
hässlich jahre vorher dachte ich so neu
geordnet ist jetzt hier so ein kupfer
ein bisschen raus gewachsen und es geht
ja alles schon dabei sich dann hässliche
haaren gelesen habe dachte ich ja ist
jetzt so und auch wenn dieser job
vielleicht nicht die körperliche
anstrengung ist ist es glaube ich
manchmal ganz gut sich eine pause zu
gönnen große entertainment formate wie
podcasts oder irgendwelche tv sendungen
machen auch alle sommerpausen als
youtuber hat man glaube ich noch nie
wirklich eine pause gemacht ich weiß
jetzt nicht von meinen kollegen ob es
mal so geplante pausen gab die einzigen
pausen die ich mitbekomme sind die die
man braucht wenn man halt kurz vorm
burnout steht oder kurz vorm
nervenzusammenbruch und ich glaube eine
pause sollte man sich schon vorher nimmt
bevor man also vor der körper es
verlangt ich habe jetzt in diesem moment
gerade das gefühl dass mein körper es
ein bisschen mehr verlangt als ich ich
fühle mich so ein bisschen
es ist so super schwer zu beschreiben
weil es ist eigentlich geht es mir ganz
gut und ich habe heute jetzt auch mit
sport wieder angefangen und haben jetzt
auch vorgenommen
auch wenn ich eine pause machen wir
damit youtube-videos dass ich halt mir
etwas suche um meine tage zu füllen ich
will jetzt nicht fünf wochen auf der
couch liegen
ich habe sowieso also die pause gibt's
aus dem grund auch weil ich mich auf ein
projekt konzentrieren möchte was ich
jetzt in den nächsten wochen machen
werde
ja doch ich muss planen und dann muss
ich es umsetzen und es geht darum dass
ich meine meine familie mit etwas
überrascht mehr will ich noch nicht
verraten weil es könnte ja sein dass
jemand zuschaut von meiner familie genau
und ich überrasche sie und das ist eine
kooperation also ich werde mit einer
kooperation wahrscheinlich mein comeback
machen leute steinigt mich bitte nicht
dafür und ich glaube aber dass es nach
so vielen jahren auch auf youtube und
auch vielen pausen auf youtube aber ich
bereue sommerpause und ich glaube ich
sollte das mir echt angewöhnen egal wie
meinen weg noch weiter gehen wird ob ich
jetzt youtube-videos mache oder
vielleicht irgendwann mal was anderes
das ich glaube ihm gerade im
entertainment-bereich oder wenn man
kreativ arbeitet was er so eine ganz
andere arbeit ist als alles was ich voll
gemacht habe dass man dass man pausen
braucht weil man hat so ein kreatives
fass und das füllt man mit inspiration
und dann wenn man was kehrt also dann
wenn man die energie braucht oder die
ideen gibt mir denn dieses fass wein und
greift sich das war schön oder greift
sich halt was raus so und jedes gefühl
gerade über diese corona zeit die ja
wirklich von uns allen das maximum
gefordert hat wir waren alle noch
niemals in so einer schweren krise
auch wenn sich das nicht so anfühlt weil
wir eigentlich ein relativ gutes leben
haben aber wir waren in einer krise drin
bzw sind es immer noch und
gerade in dieser corona zeit hat sich
dieses fast nicht mehr gefühlt und ich
habe rausgenommen rausgenommen
rausgenommen und habe irgendwann gemerkt
so scheiße ich kann den boden sehen wenn
man den boden kommt passiert ist nicht
gut das sind jetzt aber auf jeden fall
schonmal gründe warum ich diese pause
brauche eine andere sache die mir in
letzter zeit schwer auf dem herzen liegt
ich weiß nicht ob es an dieser
erschöpfung liegt oder woran genau
aber wenn ich mir den content zurzeit
auf youtube deutschen angucke ohnehin zu
bashen aber ich habe das gefühl es ist
nur noch eine reine kopie also man sieht
von allen also ich habe damals mit dem
kochen angefangen also habe ich auch so
videos gemacht sketche und die halt so
lifestyle entertainment content dann hab
ich ja immer mit dem kochen angefangen
und das ist so gut angekommen dass ich
hätte man mehr gemacht habe und das ja
dann auch irgendwann so mein extremes
steckenpferd war
wie schmeckt zum beispiel und dann habe
ich auch das kochbuch gemacht und hab da
immer mehr in dieser richtung auch
videos produziert und es wurde aber ein
bisschen eintönig weil man braucht ja
auch ab und zu mal was anderes
gerade im kreativen bereich man muss ja
auch mal was anderes machen so und
während ich aber quasi versucht habe
auch was anderes zu machen habe ich
gemerkt dass dieser koch content ja
total beliebt wurde auf youtube nicht
dass ich die erste war oder irgendwas in
der richtung dass mehrere leute format
weggenommen oder so aber es ging mir
eher darum dass oder das geht mir darum
dass wenn die youtube eröffnet man sich
irgendwie hunderte ideen wo ich das ja
ja das wollte ich auch mal einer dass
das wollte ich auch mal machen
da haben gerade zwei leute drei leute
vier leute das gleiche hochgeladen so
und das ist halt cool wenn die alle
damit cool sind cool cool cool ich bin
die letzte die irgendwas sagt aber für
mich ist das gerade noch nicht so ganz
also für mich es fällt mir zurzeit
schwer um einen punkt auf youtube zu
finden und zu sagen ich bin die person
die das macht weil viele also ich habe
ja unter dem ein video mit dem pudding
gefragt ja wenn ihr jemanden beschreiben
also wenn ihr
andere erklären sollte ich bin dann
schreibt also schreibt mal was ihr sagen
würde
und da haben so viele übers kochen und
so geschrieben was ja auch absolut
richtig ist aber ich sehe mich heute
nicht mehr so dann also ich würde jetzt
nicht hinstellen und sagen ja also ich
mach youtube-videos und da komme ich
ganz viele sind erich koch ja also ich
muss auch ehrlich mit euch sein ich habe
extrem viele tests videos gemacht
einerseits weil ich wirklich
es mag ich liebe sachen auspacken und
irgendwelchen bullshit mir angucken und
darüber reden ob mir das gefällt oder
nicht aber ich habe es echt übertrieben
auch weil weil es so einfach war es war
so einfach bzw ist schon aufwendig dass
die sachen zu bestellen und dann alles
wieder zurück zu schicken aber es war so
einfach dieses drehen so ich habe
einfach quasi meine zeit in job und
konnte es filmen und dann schneiden ich
merke aber dass diese art von videos
zwar gut bei euch an kommen und einfach
zu produzieren sind aber wenn sie dann
auf youtube oben sind guck ich sie mir
nicht mehr wirklich an und das ist halt
bei anderen videos wo ich ein bisschen
mehr herzblut reinstecken mal bisschen
also wo name ricky d hinter steckt oder
wie bei kockel zu ballern so einschnitt
wo ist der einfach tage dauert das ich
dann immer mal wieder haben mir so ein
video angucken und mir denke es war ja
nicht so und das ist halt bei vielen
videos die ich in letzter zeit gemacht
habt nicht so dass es mich nicht so
interessiert wie dieses video am ende
ist und mir ist auch aufgefallen dass
ich als videoproduzent gucke den eigenen
content ich produziere nicht so wirklich
an also ich gucke mir jetzt persönlich
nicht so wirklich test videos an
und das hat dann auch schon wieder so
ein rattenschwanz hinter sich hergezogen
soll aber was will ich denn dann
eigentlich muss ein musiker der eine
bestimmte musik macht auch genau diese
musik hören
irgendwie schon oder stellt euch mal vor
dem rapper hört die ganze schlager
produziert aber ab weil er weiß dass es
besser verkauft wird leider auch recht
gut verkauft
na ja und das war dann halt auch so ein
punkt
wo ich dachte ja was machst du hier
eigentlich die ganze zeit und nicht es
ist es total menschlich und ich
verurteile mich nicht dafür weil
irgendwo wollen wir alle unsere brötchen
verdienen und unsere miete bezahlen und
so deswegen ist es manchmal schwer auch
entscheidungen zu treffen die vielleicht
sachen verändern würden
oder wo man sich von sachen
verabschiedet von dem man eigentlich mal
gedacht hat dass die super wichtig für
einen sind ja aber ich weiß noch gar
nicht und deswegen brauche ich diese
pause
ich glaube um einfach mal aus diesem
ganzen schlamm rauszugehen einfach mal
ein paar schritte nach hinten machen und
sich mal dass alles so von von einer
anderen perspektive anschauen wenn man
mittendrin in diesem sumpf ist und die
ganze zeit eigentlich nur versucht sich
an irgendwas zu greven uns zu denken
und warum schaffen es die ganzen anderen
leute raus oder wer es dennoch mit mir
in diesem sumpf 4
oder was für probleme sind in diesen
sumpf dann ist man nicht klar wie bei
kung fu panda hier mit diesem bau sie
das singe ich werde ja ich werde halt
ich werde halt immer noch auf instagram
unterwegs sein
ich werde euch von meinem sport projekt
zeigen ich werde jetzt wahrscheinlich
keine twitch livestreams machen weil das
hat in der vergangenheit einfach nicht
funktioniert wegen der musik und ich
weiß auch nicht wie ich das sonst lösen
sollte außer wenn ich mir eigene
sportprogramme aus denken würde
deswegen mussten ding für mich bleiben
ich kann euch daraufhin seine und man
hat natürlich ein bisschen mitnehmen und
zeigen was für fortschritt ich gemacht
habe also wenn ihr mich so sehr vermisst
dass ihm also wenn es jetzt nicht paar
wochen ohne mich aus haltet und kommt
darüber
ich glaube auch dass der algorithmus
mich jetzt nicht großartig bestrafen
wird dafür dass ich ein paar wochen
pause mache ich glaube ihr werdet mich
auch gar nicht vermissen wenn ich mal so
darüber nachdenke ihr schafft ja fünf
wochen ohne mich es ist ich glaube das
einzige ich bin die einzige person die
daraus ein großes ding macht aber wenn
es da den 1
anderen draußen gibt er ist vielleicht
auch für den ist auch ein großes ding
ist dann tschüss und ein punkt würde ich
gerne noch ansprechen
zu dem thema da war das deine haare sind
hässlich ich finde allgemein hat sich
der ton auf youtube ein bisschen in den
kommentaren auf jeden fall verändert
insofern dass man jetzt sagen könnte
dass die instagram nachrichten und
kommentare hundertmal netter sind und
ich hatte das gefühl früher war das
anders rum
ich dachte früher waren die youtube
leute alle super korrekt und auf
instagram gab es dann eher so sind
diesen ein oder anderen hater aber
mittlerweile regt man echt schon ganz
schön wie backlash auch für sachen wo
ich wirklich sagen muss ich verstehe es
nicht also ich hab da jeder werbung im
letzten video gemacht und dieses produkt
sechs monate getestet also was will man
bitte noch mehr
ich habe dieses ding sechs monate
getestet mine ist kanadas zeigen das
steht da alles kommt ich zeige euch das
jetzt sonst glaubt mir das nicht hier so
sieht mein bart aus weil ich mit chili
noch das hier benutzt wie ich auch im
video gesagt habe und dann lese ich da
trotzdem so kommentare wieso warum es
jetzt um am heidhof denken ja keine
ahnung wahrheit manche interessant böse
sind und euch sachen verkaufen
wollen.die es ist einfach scheiße sind
so kann ich doch nichts dafür vergleich
mich doch bitte nicht mit irgendwelchen
dubai instruments sein ich habe noch nie
wirklich okay das kann ich auch nicht
sagen ich habe mist gebaut und das kommt
erst ein paar wochen raus und dann habe
ich dieses tor aber wenn ich jetzt so
darüber nachdenke glaube ich nicht dass
ich jemals wirklich scheiße gebaut habe
was ich damit sagen möchte es so weit
ist es einmal schwer
letztens hat jemand zu mir gesagt was
ganz gut weil es so ein gegenseitiges
druck machen
ich mach euch druck indem ich mein
supertolles fans live lebe und ihr macht
mir druck indem ihr halt auch sachen von
mir verlangt bzw halt mich belangt wenn
ich irgendwas falsch mache das ja nicht
so der fall ist na ja zu dieser
geschichte
ich hab halt reinigungs zeug beworben
was ich sechs monate getestet habe und
nach diesen sechs monaten habe ich
gesagt ja ich bin jetzt red i sechs
monate habe ich das benutzt ich finde
meine haut war noch nie schöner
jetzt ich bin überzeugt ich möchte dafür
jetzt werbung machen
naja und hat das video elf viel zu wenig
recherchiert und links bevor also dann
plötzlich werde ich damit sondern glaube
ich so oder so was verglich nun ich mir
denke ich habe noch nie wirklich
kritisch etwas hinterfragt ich
hinterfrage mein eigenes leben
vielleicht kritisch und achte bei mir
selber darauf dass ich mich ausgewogen
vegetarisch ab und zogen das sind
fleisch so ernähren dass ich in den
spiegel gucken kann oder müll und und
kann klamotten kaufen so dass ich in den
spiegel gucken kann
aber ich habe nie gesagt dass ich habe
nie gesagt dass ich irgendwie das hier
in meine mission rein nehme euch zu
sagen dass es besser oder schlechter ist
oder wie ihr leben zu leben habt es gibt
so viele menschen da draußen die
einfachen suchten einem flavour zu sagen
wie man sein leben zu leben hat und ich
finde so lange man wirklich nicht
gravierende fehler macht oder sich
verhält wie es wirklich nicht in ordnung
ist dann sollte man so ein bisschen
leben und leben lassen
ich hatte ein bisschen schießen sie
anfang an diesem video zu weinen aber
turns out ich merke aber nur um
aufgestellte mich über kommentare und
nochmal zum abschluss wo mache ich denn
dieses jahr meinen urlaub also leute
haltet euch fest
wo gibt's denn jetzt so mit diesem kanal
hin wo geht es mit meinem konto nennen
was interessiert mich denn gerade so
also ich muss sagen dass mr werde ich
glaube das war der spritzer smr werde
ich glaube ich wirklich mehr jetzt
versuchen zu verfolgen weil das ist
etwas was mir wirklich sehr viel spaß
macht und ich konsumiere so viel mehr
videos ich mache sie selber gerne ich
glaube ich habe da noch nicht selber
gecheckt dass das vielleicht etwas ist
was ich mal mehr machen sollte mich
interessieren diese ganzen themen der
psychischen gesundheit meditationen
achtsamkeit self improvement wie kann
man quasi zufriedener werden
und ich finde dass ich glaube diese
themen die mich auch interessieren
viel mehr nach außen tragen sollte das
große problem dabei ist
dass ich halt wirklich vor dieser wahl
stehe auch wenn es vielleicht nicht ganz
so dramatisch ist oder vielleicht alles
anders wird als man denkt aber ich stehe
vor dieser wahl
möchtest du die ganzen klicks und das
geld was damit dann einhergeht und
diesen erfolg möchtest du den
austauschen gegen zufriedenheit also
gegen content machen der vielleicht
nicht so viele klicks macht und nicht so
viel geld einbringt und aber da für dich
halt zufriedener macht so das ist
wirklich so ein tausch den ich eingehen
muss und es ist sehr schwer wenn man
schon mal in einer richtung glaube ich
erfolgreich war wie ich mit dem kochen
zu sagen hey vielleicht ist es ja gerade
einfach nicht das was ich machen möchte
aber dass der große unterschied wäre
dass ich das für mich auch einfach mal
kurz akzeptiere und nicht immer im
hinterkopf habe so aber du müsstest
jetzt eigentlich echt mal wieder das
machen oder du musst so ein video machen
weil die leute werden langsam nervös
oder die leute springen ab und das was
ich mich frage ist woher dieser dran
kommt irgendwie alle fliesen zu wollen
weil und wenn leute mich der abonnieren
was jetzt schon seit mehreren wochen
eigentlich schon der fall ist dass ich
eher der bus macher als abos also es
gehen mehr leute als leute dazukommen
aber das macht ja nix das macht ja nix
aus aber man ist da selber so in diesem
schlamm drin wie ich schon gesagt habe
oder ein sumpf dass man es einfach alles
nicht mehr richtig überblicken kann und
nicht mehr sehen kann
wiewohl liegen wo liegen meine eigenen
werte was ist mir wichtig man ist nur
noch so auf dieses geld muss auf dieses
dashboard von youtube was einem zeigt
was sind deine letzten zehn videos und
wie haben sie die high performance und
dann gibt es eine rangliste
und wenn du dann zum beispiel video
hochlädt und dann zeigt es dir nach drei
stunden an platz zehn von zehn ist deine
stimmung komplett im keller
und wenn das dann nach sieben stunden
platz 2 von sehen wird ist plötzlich
alles wieder in ordnung und das ist also
ich will meinen fokus von sowas komplett
fern halten
natürlich ist es irgendwo wichtig sich
selber ernähren zu können mit dem geld
man verdient aber ich glaube man hat er
auch nicht also wenn man hat schon mal
in einer sache erfolg hatte glaube ich
hängt man da so sehr daran weil man
denkt so doch das ist ja genau das also
das muss ich jetzt machen aber es gibt
ja es könnte ja noch 100 andere sachen
geben in denen man gut wäre
und ich glaube viele leute sind auch
hier weil sie einfach mich irgendwie
sympathisch finden und mein content gut
finden und vielleicht schaffe ich es ja
sogar euch zu überraschen und und noch
viel geile sachen euch anzubieten wie
ich sie vorher gemacht habe ja aber das
sehen wir dann alles jetzt habe ich euch
paar minuten von gelabert podcast darauf
habe ich zum beispiel richtig lust ja
heute ich nur mal kurz folgen ich habe
mir halt gerne sachen an wie lange sind
ich gucke mir nicht mehr so gerne kurzen
content an und kurz denn für mich schon
zehn minuten das ist mir irgendwie zu
kurz wenn ich mir angucke möchte ich da
eine halbe stunde lang das angucken
auch ich bin auf tik tok dann will ich
in dieser slot machine die ganze zeit
voll geballert werden wir denken
ein lustiges video ich raste aus
aber ja allgemein podcasts lange dokus
alle wenn die drei stunden sind gibt sie
mir hitler hier eva braun hitlers frau
zwei stunden mit alles angeguckt und ich
hab das leben naja ich sagen wollte ist
vielleicht muss ich auch mal anfangen
längeren contents machen vielleicht muss
ich mal anfangen das video zu
produzieren was ich selber konsumiere
und weggehen von dieser 2018 vanessa die
ich irgendwie einfach nicht mehr da kann
ich einfach nicht mehr mithalten oder
2017 besser gemacht sondern so und jetzt
ist aber schluss
ich wünsche euch einen schönen tag ich
geh jetzt ansehe ja ich mache einfach
ein youtube-hit super ganzes leben habe
und jetzt also schon mittlerweile spät
für uns nur